un bon anniversaire au centre georges
pompidou qui va souffler ses 20 bougies
ce week end avec trois journées portes
ouvertes au public le centre beaubourg
comme l'on dit dont l' architecture
d'avant-garde avait été très décriée
lors de son inauguration en janvier ce
sont 17 accueilli de plus depuis plus de
146 millions de visiteurs français et
étrangers
reportage aux big daniel lefebvre voici
le nouvel habit de lumière du centre
pompidou les tubulures font peau neuve
après une cure de jouvence à peu près
terminée
côté pile et côté face l'illumination
est due à jacques rouveyrollis lecteurs
hagist de johnny hallyday et autres
rockstar que s'est il passé dans le
monde depuis 20 ans un mur d'image nous
rappellent ils eu par exemple le premier
bébé éprouvette
un mariage qui commençait bien et un cow
boy à la maison blanche il y a vingt ans
le président giscard d'estaing
inaugurait le centre national voulu par
son prédécesseur georges pompidou qui
avait souhaité réunir tous les arts dans
un même lieu des l'exposition de la
maquette
la polémique s'était engagé rudement je
crois que seul l erreur monumentale du
siècle une boîte comprise ont pas d
expérience comme sur des lapins ou comme
dans les hôpitaux psychiatriques
tout le monde peut se tromper 146
millions de visiteurs en 20 ans et tous
les jours à l'ouverture une immense file
d'attenté
le centre est est la première
institution à mettre le public au centre
de sa préoccupation
ces visiteurs sont très divers là parmi
ces visiteurs de simples promeneurs qui
viennent dans la maison pour la regarder
pour monter au cinquième étage pour voir
là la vue il ya également des lecteurs
des lecteurs de la bibliothèque
rien que la bibliothèque reçoit environ
12 mille lecteurs par jour ce qui est
considérable la bibliothèque sera
bientôt rénové elle sera déplacée mais
ne fermera pas il en ira de même pour
les autres activités du centre qui
seront maintenues pendant les travaux
dont l'achèvement est prévu pour le 1er
janvier de l'an 2000
si vite et technique immédiat n'est pas
que le livre il ya le film décapant
style de musique des cd rom
des laboratoires de langues il ya
vraiment tous ici donc c'est pour tous y
compris pour les amateurs d'internet qui
coup sur place leurs cyber café mais le
centre pompidou demeure plus que jamais
le haut lieu de l'art contemporain et il
nous offre pour ses 20 ans la
quintessence de la création en france
depuis un demi siècle